Alan Arkin is one of those actors who
should have won an Oscar long before he
finally did the man was nominated twice
and he had plenty of other powerful
performances in other films as well
thankfully Arkin got his well-deserved
trophy at the 79th Academy Awards for
his performance and Little Miss Sunshine
in a movie filled with amazing actors
Arkin stands out as a larger than life
Edwin Hoover he's a dirty old man with a
foul mouth a fondness for drug use and
an incredibly grumpy disposition but
while Arkin earns plenty of laughs with
colorful language he also tugs on the
old heartstrings and scenes like the one
where he tells us tier 4 granddaughter
that she'll never be a loser so long as
she tries to accomplish her dreams you
know what a loser is
a real loser is somebody that's so
afraid of not winning they don't even
try
even though he's only in the film for a
scant 14 minutes he proved he was
definitely a winner when he snagged that
Oscar